- No, you have an anniversary
coming up though, right?
Is it three years?
- Yeah, three year--
- [Kelly] Yeah, with your wife?
- Yeah, that's right,
I have a three year--
- [Kelly] Yes, congratulations!
- Thank you!
Thank you very much.
(audience cheers)
- I'm married, I love being
married, I love my husband,
but it is interesting to
bring two worlds together.
(audience cheers)
And especially, this is
why I brought it up too.
'Cause my husband and I work,
'cause we're in the industry,
but we're of different
cloths in the industry.
He's in management and I'm
an artist, so it's different,
so, two artists, enjoy. (laughs)
- Yeah, no, for sure, I mean,
we're cut from two
different cloths as well,
she's brilliant and...
I am her husband.
- [Kelly] And you...
(laughter)
And, I sometimes
misconstrue 'and' and 'but'
- [Thomas] Yeah. (laughs)
And I'm the guy who screws
up Aaron Sorkin dialogue.
No, we do, we have our
anniversary coming up
and it's a tricky thing,
negotiating relationships
inside the industry
and all that sort of stuff, but--
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, it's mostly just has to do with
parenting and whose gonna be
around and what you're gonna do
and how close do you want your
kids to be to this industry
and all that sort of stuff.
- That is a constant
battle within myself...
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because you want them to be
a part of what you're doing,
you want them around,
but then you're like,
this isn't normal and you're
kinda being weird about it.
- We both are, like, super
working class kids, like, we...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know what I mean? I grew
up in a small town in Texas
and she grew up in Pennsylvania,
and, we don't want this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, we never, it's what
we do, it's not who we are.
- Yeah.
- And that's not exactly
what we wanna take to.
(audience claps)
- Yeah, but, at the same time,
coming from a small
town Texas girl as well,
- [Thomas] Sure.
- It's nice that, though,
that they are in it
and it's not all the (gasp)
'cause they're 'round
it all the time, so...
- Oh, she, she's gonna be so bored of it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, she's three, right?
- She is, she is.
- [Kelly] Oh, 'cause I have
a three year old, as well.
One of ours is three.
I call it a threenager.
- [Thomas] Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Full on fit.
- She has quite a lot of opinions,
she is not afraid of expressing them,
- That's kind of a bold girl, I like it.
- She's tough, she's tough as nails.
- [Kelly] You want her to be like that.
- Oh, I do, I totally do, and
she's gonna grind me down.
(laughter)
I look at it already and I'm like,
"I am a broken man already."
- Yeah, no, literally,
mine do the same thing,
I'll look at my husband like,
"Why are they so mean
sometimes? I'm like--"
- Like, I just wanna make you happy.
- [Kelly] I know, and I,
and I always do that thing
where they're like, "Why do
you always have to go to work?"
and I'm like, "Do you like your house?"
"Do you like your Barbies?"
I'm like--
- You know what, it's like, yeah,
but not as much as I like my mom.
- [Kelly] No, but that's not fair...
- And then you go (cries)
- That's not fair though,
because my mom was a single mom
and wasn't able to be
around a lot, and I'm great!
I turned out fine!
- Undeniably, undeniably.
- So, I always tell her, I'm like...
- [Thomas] Oh, no, no don't...
- [Kelly] Don't you pull that crap on me!
- Don't get me wrong,
I mean, it's definitely
one of those things
where you gotta put them
in their place about that
stuff, you know what I mean?
But it--
- Yes, I don't care what Mia's mom
gets to do with you,
that's awesome, I can't.
- [Mark] Yes, that's right.
- [Kelly] I do other things.